[Music]
a male firefly glows above a field on a
summer's night
emitting a series of enticing flashes he
hopes a nearby female will respond
with her own light show and mate with
him sadly for this male
it won't turn out quite the way he plans
a female from a different species mimics
his pulsing patterns
by tricking the male with her promise of
partnership
she lures him in and turns him into an
easy meal
he's been deceived behavioral biologists
have identified
three defining hallmarks of deception by
non-human animals
it must mislead the receiver the
deceiver must benefit
and it can't simply be an accident in
this case we know that the predatory
firefly's signal
isn't an accident because she flexibly
adjusts her flash pattern
to match males of different species
based on this definition where is animal
deception
seen in nature camouflage is a good
starting point
and one of the most familiar examples of
animal trickery
the leaf-tailed gecko and the octopus
fool the viewers by blending into the
surfaces on which they rest
other animals use mimicry to protect
themselves
harmless scarlet cane snakes have
evolved red
yellow and black patterns resembling
those of the venomous eastern
coral snake to benefit from the
protective warnings
these markings convey even some plants
use mimicry
there are orchids that look and smell
like female
wasps to attract hapless males who end
up
pollinating the plant some of these
animals benefit by having fixed
characteristics
that are evolutionarily suited to their
environments
but in other cases the deceiver seems to
anticipate the reactions of other
animals
and to adjust its behavior accordingly
sensing a threat
the octopus will rapidly change its
colors to match its surroundings
dwarf chameleons color match their
environments more closely
when they see a bird predator rather
than a snake
birds after all have better color vision
one of the more fascinating examples of
animal deception comes from the
fork-tailed drongo
this bird sits atop tall trees in the
kalahari desert
surveying the landscape for predators
and calling when it senses a threat
that sends meerkats pied battlers and
others dashing for cover
but the drongo will also sound a false
alarm when those
other species have captured prey as the
meerkats and babblers flee
the drongo swoops down to steal their
catches
this tactic works about half the time
and it provides drongos
with much of their food there are fewer
solid cases of animals using signals to
trick members of their own species
but that happens too consider the mantis
shrimp like other crustaceans it molts
as it grows
which leaves its soft body vulnerable to
attack
but it's still driven to protect its
home against rivals
so it has become a masterful bluffer
despite being fragile a newly molted
shrimp
is actually more likely to threaten
intruders
spreading the large limbs it usually
uses to strike or stab
its opponents and that works bluffers
are more likely to keep their homes than
non-bluffers
in its softened condition a mantis
shrimp couldn't withstand a fight
which is why we can be confident that
its behavior is a bluff
biologists have even noticed that its
bluffs are tactical
newly molted mantis shrimp are more
likely to bluff against
smaller rivals who are especially likely
to be driven away
it would seem that instead of just
threatening reflexively
the mantis shrimp is swiftly gauging the
situation
and predicting others behavior to get
the best result
so we know that animals can deceive but
do they do so with intent
that's a difficult question and many
scientists think we'll never be able to
answer it
we can't observe animals internal
thoughts but we don't need to know what
an animal is thinking
in order to detect deception by watching
behavior and its outcomes
we learn that animals manipulate
predators prey
and rivals and that their capacity for
deception
can be surprisingly complex do animals
have
language how do they feel pain and why
do they have
such different lifespans find out the
answers to these questions and more
with this playlist